elle compterait près de 4 millions
d'abonnés et 3 millions de documents des
notes de cours des questions et des
réponses d'examen des résumés de lecture
la plateforme stud qu est une véritable
mine d'or à l'université laval
certains étudiants l'ont adopté je
trouve qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
notes qu'on peut trouver pis c'est une
bonne plateforme pour s'entraider entre
nous ça me permet de me préparer aux
examens puis ça permet de partager
qu'est ce que nous on a créé un outil
qui est utilisé par plusieurs étudiants
mais stud aucune ne fait pas que des
heureux dans le paysage universitaire
commun et accès à du matériel ça peut
être considéré légal parce que tu payes
tes droits de scolarité et l'enseignant
qui donne sa contenu le même sens façon
ça lui appartient
dans une déclaration écrite transmise à
radio canada université laval reconnaît
que l'utilisation de la plateforme
soulève des enjeux notamment sur le
respect des droits d'auteur les
personnes qu'ils déposeraient des
contenus écrit-on sont à risque de ne
pas détenir les autorisations requises
notamment celles qui exigent les lois
applicables au canada protégeant le
droit d'auteur et ainsi d'y contrevenir
c'est du matériel qui en principe la
partie l'enseignant comme énormément
d'heures à développer qui est un fil
conducteur une originalité qu'un
objectif pédagogique
de notre point de vue ça s'assimile
peut-être dans certains cas du plagiat
devant les critiques
la plateforme sudoku a toujours rappelé
qu'elle refuse que du matériel protégé
par le droit d'auteur soient publiés sur
sa plateforme départager la nature de
ces milliers de documents demeurent
néanmoins un exercice complexe les
documents placés sur cette plateforme
pourrait laisser croire qu'ils
renferment des notes de cours et des
questions d'examen valide écrit
l'université laval alors que cela ne
pourrait pas être le cas l'université
laval met en garde ses étudiants
l'inquiétude
elle demeure c'est clair qu'il va
falloir en faire beaucoup parce que on
peut pas délivrer des diplômes au rabais
mais si ça peut aider les étudiants je
vois pas pourquoi ça
ce serait messi cdc des questions
d'examen si le malaise entourant studio
q est palpable
la plateforme continuent de gagner du
terrain la grande majorité des
universités du québec doivent également
jongler avec cette réalité ici à diesse
une radio canada québec